JOANNE STUBBE: The way we teach
the course is we show them
that all of these
chemical transformations
can be described by 10
pretty simple steps.
And if you understand
the basic chemistry
of these simple steps, you can
really understand almost all
of the kinds of interconversions
you see and basic metabolism.
And what you'll see is while
this looks overwhelming,
really, with a few
central pathways,
which is what we focus on
in this course-- glycolysis,
fatty acid oxidation,
biosynthesis,
sugar biosynthesis as well as
degradation, the Krebs cycle,
which feeds into the
respiratory chain--
knowing those
central reactions--
almost everything in
metabolism feeds in and out
of these pathways.
And so then, it
really is a question
of what is the
environment like and how
do you enhance
breakdown of sugar
under the appropriate
environment
versus synthesize sugar under
a different environment.
So then it's a
question of regulation.
So what you're going
to learn in this course
is really focused on
central metabolism.
And it doesn't
matter whether you
study a bacteria or a human,
the central metabolism
is pretty much the same.
The thing that's different
is the detailed regulation
and the complexity
of the regulation.
And we don't really talk that
much about regulation in 5.07.
What we do is
introduce you to five
or six basic regulatory
mechanisms that
are used over and over again.
But then, regulation is
really distinct, even
between organisms.
And so then that becomes
much more complicated.
And when you go off and
become a biochemist,
you've got to study
your own system
and figure out what
the environment is.